wir lassen uns die Situation rund um den
kachowka Staudamm einschätzen von Simon
Schlegel Ukraine Experte von der Crisis
Group guten Tag
guten Tag Russland und die Ukraine geben
sich gegenseitig die Schuld an der
Zerstörung was halten Sie denn für die
wahrscheinlichste Ursache
ja grundsätzlich würde ich in dieser
Situation jetzt noch keine
Schuldzuweisungen warten ich denke das
ist eine sehr komplizierte Situation ich
habe auch nicht das nötige Ingenieurs
müssen wissen dafür um jetzt hier
anzusetzen zu können welche Art von
Sprengler man braucht um so einen Darm
zu sprechen oder ob der auch jetzt zum
Beispiel am Wasserdruck
gebrochen sein kann nachdem er ja schon
sehr lange mit dem Kriegsgebiet ist und
von beiden Seiten
öfter mit kleinen Kalorien Waffen mit
Arterie beschossen wurde ich würde hier
noch nicht wagen eine klare
schulterweise zu machen es ist natürlich
so dass die ganze Situation erst dadurch
entstehen konnte das Russland die
Ukraine illegal angegriffen hat wenn die
russischen Panzer nie bis an den Japan
gewollt werden am 24 Februar 2022 dann
müssen wir heute diese Frage nicht
diskutieren von daher hilft auf jeden
Fall eine Vorschrift schon mal Russland
und Russland hat ja über den ganzen
Winter hinweg immer immer wieder auch
ohne das zu verneinen in der Ukraine
lebenswichtige Infrastruktur ganz
gezielt zerstört von daher passt es
schon in die Handlungsweise Russlands
aber hier jetzt sagen zu können Russland
ist ganz klar im Profiteur von dieser
katastrophalen Situation das fällt mir
auch schwer deswegen würde ich hier noch
ein paar Tage warten bis wir mehr
Informationen mehr Daten haben welche
Folgen ergeben sich denn aus dem
Dammbruch ganz konkret kann man schon
sagen welche Seite sozusagen mehr
darunter zu leiden haben wird
jetzt im Moment ganz konkret ist es eine
große Überschwemmung eine riesige
Flutwelle die also den Unterlauf des
napfers herunter wählst und sich ins
Napa Delta hineinwälst die Geografie
jetzt in dieser konkreten in diesem
kurierten Flussabschnitt ist so dass das
hohe Ufer das ist von den Ukrainern
kontrolliert das rechte Ufer dort wo die
stadtperson liegt und das tief gelegene
Ufer des sandige Ufer das wird von den
russischen Besatzungsmächten
kontrolliert die sind dort tief
eingegraben das heißt deren Stellungen
deren Soldaten die müssen viel weiter
sich vom Flussufer zurückziehen um jetzt
in höheres Gelände zu gelangen von daher
also reines der militärische Effekt des
der Flutwelle die der trifft die Russen
erstmal
verheerende als die Ukraine die Russen
haben sich ja in dieser Gegend sehr
stark
eingegraben sehr stark ihre Stellungen
ausgebaut in Erwartungen in der lang
angekündigten gegen Offensive der
Ukraine diese gehen Offensive kann jetzt
wahrscheinlich in diesem ab
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
sicherlich nicht stattfinden weil die
Situation so chaotisch ist und weil die
Kinder sicher auch viel der Kräfte jetzt
brauchen um einfach mal diese Situation
zu regulieren das heißt das kann sein
dass die Russen dadurch ein bisschen
wenn Sie das waren ein bisschen Zeit
gewonnen haben aber auf lange Sicht
würde ich sagen ist es
ist auch für die Russen keinen Gewinn
also es gibt Nachteile für für beide
Seiten wir versuchen das gleich noch mal
nacheinander und Detail zu besprechen
aber bleiben jetzt gerade noch mal weil
sie es auch gerade angetextet haben bei
der ukrainischen Gegend Offensive die
erwartet wird bzw auch seit einigen
Tagen wohl schon so läuft also welche
Folgen wird jetzt der Dammbruch dafür
haben
eine Erwartung vielleicht von den Russen
war das zumindest ein Vorstoß der
Ukrainer über den Nepper direkt von
raison aus stattfinden würde das wäre
allerdings eine sehr komplizierte
Operation gewesen für die die Ukraine
eigentlich wenig Bedarf hatten weil sie
ja auch auf dem freien Feld im Süden der
Region saporisa die Russen direkt
konfrontieren können das heißt was hier
vielleicht passiert ist ist das eine
angriffsachse weniger ist und es ist
jetzt viel Chaos das heißt die Ukraine
werden jetzt erstmal damit beschäftigt
sein diese Situation zu regulieren die
Bevölkerung der Stadt Saison und den
umliegenden Ortschaften zu evakuieren es
wird vielleicht ein oder zwei wichtige
militärstellung von denen auch davon
betroffen sein aber wahrscheinlich
ist das eine Frage der Zeit er als das
jetzt deswegen die Gegend Offensive gar
nicht stattfinden kann das glaube ich
nicht also allenfalls eine Verzögerung
meinen sie auch die von von Russland
kontrollierte Krim wird ja mit Wasser
aus dem Stausee versorgt spricht das aus
ihrer Sicht gegen eine russische
Urheberschaft
nicht unbedingt denn die
Russen haben ja schon oft auch
Taktiken angewendet die sehr stark auch
der Bevölkerung in der von Russland
kontrollierten Gebieten schaden wenn es
nur daran denken wie stark die Städte
zerstört sind die Russland erobert hat
und jetzt quasi als seine eigenen
erzählt
hat schon einmal acht Jahre ohne diesen
Kanal
überlebt das heißt die Leute dort haben
alternative Wege gefunden wie sie an
Trinkwasser gelangen über Brunnen über
Kanister
überflaschen und das Problem ist
eigentlich das größte ist für die
Landwirtschaft die eben über diesen
Kanal Wasser für die Bewässerung erhält
und wissen ja mitten im Sommer das heißt
in einigen Wochen ist Erntezeit und
wahrscheinlich ist er sehr viele Bauern
jetzt auch der Krim und aber auch in der
im südlichen Teil der Region jetzt das
ein sehr großer Verlust dass sie dieses
Wasser nicht haben und dass ihnen
wahrscheinlich jetzt ähm Reich
bestandene Felder vertrocknen
bange Blicke richten sich jetzt auch auf
das AKW saporicia denn das wird ja auch
mit Wasser aus dem Stausee gekühlt
welche Informationen haben sie dazu
bei dem AKW in saporica ist es ein
bisschen so dass die widrigen Umstände
eigentlich jetzt ein bisschen dieser
Situation zu Gute kommen weil da dieses
Kraftwerk ja schon länger unter Beschuss
steht gibt es dort eine Delegation der
der internationale
energieorganisation die dort also die
Augen
offen hat und den Finger Impuls hat das
heißt eine Situation wie wir z.B
tschernoby hatten das Tage lang
vertuscht wird wenn etwas schief geht
das können wir dort wahrscheinlich jetzt
nicht erleben das heißt es ist schon mal
eine Delegation der das das andere was
für dafür spricht dass die ja ja selber
gesagt hat dass jetzt keine direkte
Gefahr besteht ist das eben das
Kühlwasser für dieses Atomkraftwerk noch
mal in einem separaten reserv war
gehalten wird das abgedämmt ist von dem
stause selber das heißt selbst wenn dort
der wasserpegelt sich jetzt um einige
Kilometer zurückzieht gibt es immer noch
Wasser jetzt für die nächsten Tage und
Wochen um das Kraftwerk zu kühlen es
braucht jetzt auch nicht so viel
Kühlwasser im Moment weil eben durch den
ständige Beschuss ist ja auch schon auf
ein Minimum heruntergefahren ist und der
nur noch Strom für sich selber für die
eigenen Bedarfe produziert das heißt
eigentlich können wir davon können wir
sagen dass
die schwierige Situation und der dieses
Kraftwerk von seit vielen Monaten lebt
das beschlossen wird die ganze Zeit
kommt jetzt in dieser Situation
eigentlich fast ein bisschen zugute also
keine unmittelbare Gefahr für das
Kraftwerk für jedenfalls die die erste
Einschätzung auch wenn sie jetzt keinen
Ingenieur sind aber trotzdem stellt sich
ja die Frage wie geht denn diese
Situation dort jetzt weiter ist dieser
Stau dann irgendwie noch zu retten wie
ist jetzt was ist zu erwarten in den
nächsten Tagen wie wird sich die
Situation entwickeln
haben bereits gesagt der Staudamm ist
nicht mehr zu retten der Starter ist
jetzt ganz unter der Wasseroberfläche
verschwunden und wird wahrscheinlich
durch die riesigen Wasserdruck der jetzt
da auf den einwirkt noch weiter
beschädigt das heißt ein großer Teil
dieses Staus ist der ungefähr viermal so
groß ist wie der Bodensee wird sich
jetzt entleeren wird in mehrere herunter
ins Schwarze Meer fließen und eine
riesige Fläche wird wahrscheinlich mit
mit Fläche wird jetzt an der Sonne
schmoren und das Kraftwerk selber wird
dadurch wahrscheinlich einige Kilometer
vom Wasser entfernt sein und es werden
große Ingenieurs Arbeiten gemacht werden
müssen um das Kühlwasser wieder in die
Nähe zu bringen und all das natürlich in
einem tiefsten Gebiet das sind sehr
große Herausforderungen die
natürlich unter diesen
unter diesen Gegebenheiten sehr viel zu
meistern ich habe auch gelesen das ist
immer wieder zu Explosionen kommt weil
Minen entlang des Flusses auch betroffen
sind
genau also es ist eines der Stärke am
stärksten vermieten Gebiete der Welt
gerade das linke
Ufer des Nepper wo die Russen ja schon
seit Monaten einen Vorstoß der Ukrainer
erwarten das ist sehr stark für ihn dort
ist der Boden ist sehr sandig das heißt
der wird jetzt zum Teil weggetragen
viele dieser Minen werden mit dem Wasser
mitgespült oder der Boden über ihm wird
abgetragen so dass sie dann in einer
geringen Höhe sind und und vielleicht
explodieren wenn sie nicht explodieren
sollten das heißt es ist dem dem ganzen
anderen umwelteinflussen die jetzt in
diesem Wasser mit Richtung Schwarzes
Meer getragen werden sind auch sehr
viele Termine und auch nicht explodierte
Kampfstoffe mit dabei also eine ganz
gefährliche muss man sagen und in jedem
Fall verheerende Situationen das waren
die Einschätzungen von Simon Schlegel
Ukraine Experte von der Crisis Group
vielen Dank für das Gespräch